the moment you find out that the worst
thing in the world has happened to
someone that you truly love with all
your heart you feel like you're drowning
and can't get out from under it
Ed Sheeran and his wife Cherry Seaborn
get emotional reflecting on her cancer
diagnosis I'm just living life and
having experiences and I'm open about it
the Grammy winners Disney plus
documentary Ed Sheeran at the sum of it
all dropped Wednesday and dives into the
personal and intimate events in 2022
that inspired him to complete his album
subtract
[Music]
Cherry who has remained largely out of
the spotlight details the moment doctors
found a tumor in her arm when she was
six months pregnant and says the
diagnosis inspired her to take part in
the documentary got diagnosed with
cancer at the start of the year which
was like a massive it made me massively
reflect on like our mortality Ed says he
tried to convince himself that
everything would be okay but it wasn't I
kept saying to you that it was just
a lump and not to worry the doctor was
basically like this is really bad back
in March Ed announced his new album will
drop May 5th and revealed it was a was
admired by a
suit that he says changed his life
mental health and the way he views music
and art first Cherry learning about the
tumor while pregnant with no route to
treatment until after the birth then
more tragedy struck suddenly my best
friend Jamal dies
I was spiraling through fear depression
and anxiety we've lost it just took over
my life pain comes at a cost but we got
this need respite lead time dry she'll
be fine she'll be fine Ed explained that
as an artist he didn't feel like he
could release an album that didn't
accurately represent where he is in life
so this record is purely that it's
opening the trap door to his soul I know
I'm in a position now where people know
me and people listen to my music people
come to concerts but like if you strip
it all back and just have me as a
musician as a songwriter that's that's
the moment that you look for not not
everything else it's like the real real
moments back in February Ed hinted at
all that when he addressed his recent
absence from social media I've had some
turbulent things been happening in my
personal life so I just didn't really
feel like being online and pretending to
be something I'm not when I wasn't
feeling like that I
at where he was a
kid Rising his
pay-per-view a
okay I'm in love with the shape of you
push and pull like a magnetic I could
lose this court case and life goes on
but life doesn't really go on if the
person you love most in the world isn't
in it you know Ed and cheery tied the
knot in 2019 and after learning that
Cherry's diagnosis was much less severe
than they were initially told she was
able to have a successful surgery
following the birth of their second
daughter